the goal of this video is to appreciate
some of the structures that you see even
in unicellular organisms so this right
over here is a picture of the amoeba
chaos carolinensi
and what you see here is a projection
coming off from the main part of the
cell and this is called a pseudopod
which is referring to it being a false
foot the pod is coming from the same
root word as podiatry which is referring
to the foot and what i really want you
to appreciate this is used by amoeba
either to move around or could be even
used to attack something that it wants
to engulf and think about what it might
take to be able to do this to be able to
grow this type of a pseudo foot this
type of a false foot you need all sorts
of microstructures in here that will
extend or contract as necessary and
think about the machinery that you need
to do that and so the key realization is
sometimes we just imagine cells as these
bags of fluid with a few things floating
around but there are these incredibly
complex structures and biologists even
today don't fully understand how
everything works and they're studying
how these things actually come to be
now another structure that you will
often see on unicellular organisms that
either help them move around or even
help move other things around are cilia
so this right over here is a picture of
oxytrica triphalax which is a
unicellular organism it's a eukaryote
and you can clearly see these
projections from its body here these
hair-like structures remember this is a
unicellular organism if we were to it's
actually a fairly it's a decent sized
one that would be about something like
that would be about 30 micrometers right
over there or 30 millionths of a meter
or 30 thousandths of a millimeter so
small by our scale but it's actually
pretty big on the scale of it being a
cell and once again these cilia tend to
move in unison to either allow the
microorganism to move around or
sometimes they're used to move other
things around for example the cells that
line your lungs will have cilia that are
used to move things up or down to move
some of the saliva or any particles that
are in there
now oxytrica triphalax is particularly
interesting as a eukaryote because it
doesn't just have one nucleus it can
have two nuclei
and within the nucleus its dna can be
extremely fragmented most organisms have
a reasonable number of chromosomes human
beings have 23 pair
that's actually a fairly large number
oxytrica triphalax could have thousands
of chromosomes and what's really
interesting about oxytrica triphalax is
how it mates when it is under stress it
will merge with another oxytrica
triphalax and instead of producing
another offspring they mingle their dna
together so by mating they change each
other's genetic makeup which is
fascinating and depending on your
perspective highly romantic now another
related idea is instead of having many
cilia some unicellular organisms will
just have one large thing that looks
like a tail that they can whip around to
move
so this right over here is a commonly
studied green algae it's called
clamidimonas and you can see very
clearly here this flagellum this
tail-like structure and this is
extremely thin we're seeing it under a
very powerful microscope right over here
but just to get a sense of scale
a micrometer here would be about
that so the width of this flagellum
flagellum would be the singular if we
were talking about many of these we
would say flagella this is about
one-fourth of a micrometer another way
of thinking about it you could put four
thousand of these side by side and you
would have the width of a millimeter so
extremely extremely small but once again
it really is amazing that these what
seem like simple organisms to us are
actually quite complex there's a whole
study of how these flagella move around
how the the the cell can spin it around
so it allows it to move if you were to
actually decompose what's going on in
this part of the cell it's actually
quite complex it's biological machinery
going on so once again these cells are
not these just bags of just a few things
floating around they're incredibly
complex structures that we are still
trying to understand